you know was tough so what was what was
the blowback like when when did Pierce
reach out so I'd obviously tweeted and
then went to bed you know and then got
up the next day and I was did you see
the picture that put to Pi the why
Always me once it was batell the it
again so I I photoshopped a picture of
Manchester City player batelli famously
pulled his Jersy up why Always me I
super imposed a picture of me that I had
in me photo real selfie like messing
around I was wasn't drunk but I was
pulling a shoe for face so I
superimposed almost like my drunk face
on one then a superimposed I did the
shoe for I think GQ and and they put a
halo over my head OB because I'm such a
well behaved man in society and I'm
known in my industry for being impecably
behaved so they put a halo over my head